or it's if that's another thing about
having a limited amount of weight
classes when you jump up chan is crazy
man yeah he's like 174 175 on fight day
yeah fighting guys 190 yeah but with a
lot of energy Z yeah that's interesting
is that his age I think it's probably
O'Neal's
yeah I think it's probably a good mood
though at his age you know I mean he's
back from UFC Ultimate Fighter wanted
inside we knew they liked on the show
that he was the one that would go
forever just crazy awesome Joe's not
gonna stop I mean when when he beat
mickey gall that way I was I was
incredibly impressed you know like this
kid might test him he didn't test him at
all I mean it was amazing so prime Diego
Sanchez performance 15 years into the
game I mean it doesn't even not even
just into dust just into the UFC yeah he
had amateur fights and our professional
fights rather before the UFC he's been
in the UFC for fifteen or at least 14
right 2004-2005 was yeah we shot at
2004-2005 so yeah what's that
yes I'm we're somewhere in the
neighborhood of 15 years just amazing
that he's so enthusiastic about it still
yeah they'll give him a vase for his top
of his mantelpiece on his fire or
something carriage clock or something
just to recognize it 15 years yeah yeah
that's that's a long time in a combat
sport a long time so that's the other
thing man that is not the norm
that's the deviation right don't leave
you got it for I made it nine years in
the UFC eight years actually and you
know I didn't have that many fights I
broke down I fell apart
yeah that's pretty average you know I
was like woe is me and then when you
look at the data it's like oh no I'm
just average 35 that's that's when you
start fall apart when you